[Aplausos]
gente o convite que me fizeram foi pra
conversar com vocês sobre biologia
mais especificamente sobre águas
marinhas
você já tá falando dos anos água viva o
qq água viva tem a ver com uma pessoa
que é advogada e que pesquisa fim de
vida
mas não é qualquer água viva gente nós
vamos conversar sobre essa água viva e
ela se chama twitter op dormir bonita
ela né
o nome dela é super difícil de falar a
torre tops doni é considerada único ser
vivo e mortal do planeta terra
isso mesmo ela não morre é o único ser
que nós temos notícia em todo o planeta
que não experimenta a sua própria
finitude confesso para vocês que quando
me contaram essa história eu senti uma
inveja profunda dessa água viva
primeiro porque ela é linda quase gisele
bünchen das águas vivas
segundo porque eu fiquei pensando como
seria bom não experimentar a finitude
direto pra sempre
não tem que pensar na morte aí eu fui
entender melhor como funciona esse
processo de mortalidade dela porque
fiquei com medo que imagina ser aquela
festa bonita sim é ela morrer até ela
não morrer na verdade vai ficar assim
para sempre como funciona isso
ele descobriu o seguinte que atue tops
daniela tem um processo de
envelhecimento que quando ela chega na
fase de envelhecimento à breca o
organismo dela breca esse envelhecimento
e ela volta para um estágio de pólipo é
como se nós seres humanos quando
atingimos mais ou menos uns 70 anos
voltaremos para um estágio mais
rudimentar do que o estágio embrionário
o pólipo na em biologia e se compara a
um estágio anterior do embrião
imaginei isso foi bom
quero num sei imortal crescer menos do
que um embrião março essas da história
do gtop achei linda maravilhosa mas não
quero muito obrigado porque porque eu
gosto de ver interagindo com as pessoas
eu gosto de estar viva e acho que vocês
também pra gente poder conversar pra
gente poder dançar pra gente poder sair
com os amigos abraçar os nossos amores e
não pode fazer nada disso porque ela
está num estágio extremamente rudimentar
experimentando essa tal da imortalidade
e aí eu comecei a pesquisar porque que
ela desperta tantos sentimentos porque
quando a gente olha para a torre tops
dormir
a gente fica meio enciumado com essa
característica dela porque todos nós
seres humanos temos dificuldade com a
morte
independente de onde a gente mora de
qual é a nossa cor
a nossa orientação sexual qual é a nossa
religião
existe um sentimento que nos une
enquanto humanos
o medo da morte o medo de sofrer o medo
de não termos mais os nossos amores
o medo de sermos esquecidos e esse medo
tem propulsionado inúmeras pesquisas ao
redor do mundo e ao longo da história
na china imperial os imperadores
contratavam alquimistas para que
fizessem poções mágicas elixires da
juventude
a idéia era que quando se pps essas
posições se adquirisse a imortalidade
mas só que acontecia com muitos deles
eles bebiam e morreu imediatamente
então aquilo que era para ser a da
imortalidade acelerar o processo de
morte
isaac newton desconhecem a gente conhece
isaac newton da lei da gravidade
ele também deixou escrito
uma fórmula da imortalidade saber disso
nilton deixou um caderninho escrito uma
fórmula que seria supostamente capaz de
transformar qualquer metal em ouro e
mais do que isso essa substância quando
ingerida pelo ser humano
daria ao ser humano a imortalidade
essa história de uma substância que
transforma metais qualquer metades em
ouro é antiga e muito recente também
quem gosta de harry potter
lembra da pedra filosofal
a pedra filosofal é um conceito da
alquimia que existe há muitos e muitos
séculos e ela parte de um pressuposto de
que um dia nós vamos descobrir uma
substância que vai transformar qualquer
metal em ouro e que vai nos dar a dádiva
da imortalidade e eu pergunto pra vocês
o que é que nos faz humanos
o que nós estamos fazendo com a nossa
humanidade
hoje nós estamos pesquisando a
imortalidade também só mudou a forma da
pesquisa jovens empreendedores estão
colocando muito dinheiro em pesquisas
atuais para se descobrir a imortalidade
esse jovem dizem frases como eu tenho
raiva da morte a morte nunca fez sentido
para mim a morte é um problema a ser
resolvido
eu tenho raiva da morte o que eu quero é
que elas e danny
o que eu quero é que o filho pra sempre
imortal não é verdade
vejam só as mulheres vão me entender
vocês conhecem aqueles longas de capa de
revista do tipo os 60 são os próximos 40
e os 50 são os próximos trinta tem um
slogan um maravilhoso
os 90 serão os próximos 50
esse jogo é de matuzalém só deixo o nec
nome legal que matuzalém fondation tá
prometendo pra gente que nós vamos
chegar com 90 anos com corpinho de 50
que com 90 anos nós não vamos ter bico
de papagaio dor na coluna e não ter ruga
que ficou 90 a gente vai aparecido com
50 significa dizer que nós estamos
aumentando a nossa longevidade não é
verdade
e aí eu pergunto pra vocês o que nos faz
humanos o que nos faz humanos estão
prometendo muitos cientistas que nós em
breve seremos capazes de viver mil anos
em 2045
nós vamos conseguir transplantar a nossa
mente a nossa consciência tão chique e
que daqui a pouquinho nós vamos chegar
às farmácias e comprar uma pílula que
vai congelar o envelhecimento
será que quando nós somos capazes de
fazer tudo isso nós teremos imortais
ou nós mudaremos o nosso conceito de
morte
será que se tirarmos a nossa consciência
e colocarmos ela em outro lugar ou em
outro ser
nós continuaremos vivos será que o que a
gente está fazendo é e mortalidade com
uma nova forma de morrer o que nos faz
humanos
eu acredito que o que nos faz humanos é
a consciência da nossa finitude que é a
consciência de que nós somos seres
finitos que nos move que a gente acorda
todos os dias e faz tudo que a gente faz
trabalho amores desamores descobertas
obras-primas porque a gente sabe que a
gente vai acabar
será que um dia a gente descobre que nós
não vamos acabar mas nós ainda seremos
capazes de fazer tudo o que a gente faz
hoje quando o eric clapton naquela
música till reva que ele fez para o
filho criança que tinha acabado de
morrer quando clapton suplica para o
filho dele
você me reconheceria no paraíso tem
poesia mais linda e mais triste sobre a
finitude do que essa tenha humanidade
maior do que esta súplica de um pai que
o quadro está mostrando pra gente é que
apesar e ainda que ele seja o rei das
guitarras
ele é humano como qualquer um de nós e
como qualquer um de nós ele tem medo de
ser esquecido com a morte
já pensaram se você também tem esse medo
mas são sentimentos que a morte causa em
todos nós o que nos faz ser humanos
o que nos move o que nos faz levantar
todos os dias
de novo eu acredito que a nossa finitude
que é a certeza de que nós não estaremos
mais aqui e que a gente quer deixar algo
perguntaram por bill gates o que ele
achava dessa galera que tá botando muito
dinheiro na imortalidade
afinal de contas o bill gates um dos
homens mais ricos do mundo se esse
negócio de dinheiro ele deve querer
botar o dinheiro dele também
o bill gates disse assim eu acho muito
egocêntrico que enquanto pessoas
morreram de tuberculose e malária
os ricos se preocupem com a própria
mortalidade
o que o game está dizendo é que a gente
precisa assumir a nossa finitude
o que ele está dizendo é que a gente
precisa entender que a morte faz parte
da vida e que a gente morre todos os
dias
a gente morre quando é demitido de um
emprego
a gente morre quando o namorado termina
com a gente a gente morre quando tá
fazendo aquela festa de casamento
seis meses preparando a festa de
casamento a festa dura seis horas
acabou a gente morre todos os dias e
todos os dias a gente já nasce a morte
faz parte da vida
o que vocês falam com uma pessoa quando
a pessoa perde alguém quando ela
experimenta morte
a gente normalmente diz assim tudo passa
deus sabe o que faz na verdade o que a
gente fala isso
no fundo essa frase é muito piegas
essas frases e elas resolvem muita coisa
todo mundo fala que tudo vai passar mas
quem está vivendo um momento acha que
aquilo não vai passar nunca porque a
gente faz isso porque isso é uma forma
de consolo porque nós não damos conta do
silêncio que a morte a morte um vazio é
um grande silêncio e nós seres humanos
estamos acostumados a oralizar tudo a
gente fala demais fala inclusive quando
não deve falar todos nós fazemos isso
todos nós olhamos pra morte e achamos
que a gente pode dar conta dela
só que a gente se esquece que é o
contrário do que os empreendedores do
vale do silício entendem a morte não é
um problema a ser resolvido é um
mistério a ser experimentado por todos
nós e quando a gente deixa de
experimentar esse mistério a gente se
desumaniza a gente abre mão do que nós
temos de mais humanos que a certeza da
nossa finitude
a organização mundial de saúde tem um
dado de 2016 que diz
a cada dez mortes no mundo seis são
feitas são causadas por doenças crônicas
significa dizer que 60% das pessoas que
morrem no mundo morre de uma morte
avisada que uma morte avisada
eu sei que eu tenho uma doença e eu sei
que essa doença vai me causar a morte
pelo menos em teoria daqui um tempo x ou
y 60% de nós vamos morrer de doenças
crônicas
nós precisamos falar sobre a morte o
desafio
se vocês hoje tivesse que escolher como
vocês querem morrer escolha vocês fariam
6 em duas opções
morri de susto ou seja do meu já à noite
e não acordar o receber um diagnóstico
de uma doença crônica progressiva e que
vai te levar à morte daqui pouco tempo o
que você escolheria
muitos de vocês devem ter pensado que
morreu de susto morrer disto não
possibilita com que a gente se despeça
não possibilita com que a gente feche
ciclos e nós seres humanos a gente
sempre acha que vai ter um outro dia já
experimentaram consolar o amigo que
estar triste por qualquer coisa até o
carro
imagina muito bravo porque bateu o carro
a gente vira assim olha fica calmo vai
dormir nada melhor do que um dia após o
outro com uma noite no meio e se o dia
seguinte não chegar
nós não damos conta dessa idéia
a gente não vive achando que o dia
seguinte não chega a gente acha que ele
sempre chega e a grande verdade gente é
que a morte precisa ser vista por todos
nós como nossa companheira
a gente precisa falar de morte
a gente precisa pensar sobre morretes
a gente precisa escrever sobre morte há
um ano atrás mais ou menos eu recebi
essa cadeira de presente de uma aluna
ela foi me dar esse presente muito
tímida com a professora eu tô com medo
danado de dar esse presente porque minha
mãe achou que eu era louca de comprar
uma cadeira para tirar mas eu falei com
minha mãe que pesquisava sobre a
finitude que fazia sentido
ela me deu essa carreira e hoje essa
cadeira no meu quarto
ela tá junto com as fotos do meu filho
com as fotos do meu marido com os meus
livros porque todos os dias quando eu
acordo e todos os dias quando eu vou
dormir eu olho para essa carreira e
lembro que o importante da vida é o aqui
eo agora eu nasci morrendo
eu nasci com uma cardiopatia congênita
transposição das grandes artérias em
vitória no espírito santo e foi
transferida para o instituto do coração
com dois dias de vida
durante a transferência
os médicos disseram para os meus pais
que eu morreria
eu tive inúmeros paradas cardíacas
durante a transferência
eu não morri como vocês podem perceber
mas o experimento em uma outra situação
e essa faz menos tempo
eu tenho um filho que vai fazer três
anos quando eu quis engravidar eu
procurei vários médicos para saber se
poderia ou não engravidar e ouvi de um
desses médicos que eu poderia assim
engravidar mas eu precisava saber se eu
queria estar viva para criar o meu filho
porque ela achava que morreria na mesa
de parto
eu engravidei
obviamente eu não fiquei com essa médica
eu engravidei eu tive o meu filho mas eu
entrei na sala de parto chorando e
pedindo para que não me deixassem morrer
meu filho está vivo tá lindo o costume
de chamar ele do filho da felicidade mas
todas as minhas experiências me fizeram
perceber depois de alguns anos de
terapia que eu pesquiso sobre direitos
de pessoas em fim de vida porque eu
sempre estive indevida porque todos nós
estamos em fim de vida e quando a gente
pensa que a nossa vida pode terminar
amanhã a gente pára para pensar o que
nós gostaríamos de fazer com a nossa
vida e quando a gente fala de pacientes
com aquela doença crônica que a
organização mundial de saúde disse que
60% de nós teremos ou seja com pessoas
que vão morrer dependentes que vão
precisar de ajuda que vão precisar de
cuidados
quando a gente pensa nessa situação
pensar sobre a finitude faz ainda mais
sentido
por isso o convite que eu faço pra vocês
é que pensem sobre a própria morte
não é a morte televisionada não é a
morte de vocês escrevam um testamento
vital inscrevam como vocês gostariam de
ser cuidados quando vocês estiverem com
uma doença crônica e incurável numa
situação de terminalidade façam esse
exercício
olhem pra dentro de vocês o testamento
vital permite e possibilita com que a
gente tenha a gentileza de olhar para
dentro de nós mesmos e verificar o que é
importante na nossa vida
o testamento vital permite com que a
gente olhe para a torre tops doni e
pense que o belo da vida não é ser
imortal que o belo da vida é viver ela
sei se desenvolver e crescer
envelhecer e morrer porque quando a
gente né da morte agente nega a nossa
humanidade agente nega a nossa
existência e aí a gente vai viver
segundos minutos horas dias meses e anos
vamos fugir da morte vamos virar a
esquina e encontrar com ela porque a
grande verdade da vida é que a morte
sempre surpreende muito obrigado
[Música]